hey guys is dense the founder take care
and I'm David Griffin your resident
comic book in video game guru and this
is a review of the hobbit desolation of
Smaug the second in the The Hobbit
trilogy Hobbit trilogy yeah wow really
directed by Peter Jackson you're dying
written by about four people it's nice
eating with el Toro still getting a
little credit even though he hasn't been
involved in the project of years so
we'll talk about general thoughts and
then we'll get into spoiler so just a
warning for you guys will let you know
we get into spoiler section so so um my
overall thoughts are I like this a lot
better than the first one so the pacing
was better it wasn't as slow there was
more things about it was better tone it
was like a serious tone to it yeah less
jokey yeah and i just got a more Lord of
the Rings feel to it so what about you I
agree i was those much better I i think
you know i was first announced they're
gonna make it to three movies and like
this is the shortest book of the whole
series doesn't need to be made into
three movies but i think we could have
shortened the first one you just made it
shorter but i'm glad this one got to the
meat that everything I mean they're
really expansion the book the books
don't link to lord of the rings that
much there's on all this stuff with you
know going on that we see what they're
really they're doing that with this one
not to spoil anything but I like that
they're doing that in a way I don't mind
they're changing things I like the kind
of linking to the the trilogy so you
could like you know essentially watch
all six which take you oh yeah they're
adding you know Legolas is in this in
this is great to have easy hit he's not
in the hobbit book right they they put
them in to create a link yeah and it's
it's great having him bad like having
him back like okay this feels like a
lord of the rings film it was nice to
have him back and then you have a
tauriel which is Evangeline Lilly
character which is totally brand-new
made up character and a love interest
for leg a little of interest which I
thought she was great in yeah she was
great i thought if anything I think she
stole some of the scenes like every time
she was in his teens like wow she's
really good ever really seen her in much
since lost and I I liked her in lost but
that she was great in this so she has
this elven look to her as well just you
know kind of like Liv Tyler dries except
for Liv Tyler was more like the you know
more magical I'm a you know princess
type and dreams like the more bad
ass I'm gonna kick your ass tight right
she's kind of lower-class was that it
was I see a low class like cuz they all
look so regal and stand to have long
hair but she was kind of low class I
mean she couldn't she wasn't partying
with everybody she always kind of felt
left out and I enjoyed that and she was
the badass fighter yeah she's all she's
as good as legolas yeah she could hold
her own it was great i mean some of that
slimy some of the boilers later but like
the the action sequences were great yes
yes blend of good comedy and just
everything going on and there's great
cast I mean Luke Evans mean in the movie
was great yeah as a bard the Bowman yeah
yeah Luke Evans was great I think he I
think he fit very well into this
universe and in speaking of the action
sequences which we'll get into more
detail in the spoiler section they were
just more more memorable yeah you know
there's more you know like the barrel
seen in the scenes with smog like they
just you know they were just more impact
out there in the first one which I in
everything it's not like they're bad
action senses by I don't ever go back
and go man I got you know like with with
a few hours I'm like yeah man that fight
it at helm awesome yeah like and then
even see that again even Fellowship
which had less once a less action the
other two even fellowship that's seen at
the end by the river you know when
Aragorn is like Pope books puts up a
sword like this and it's like starts
taking down all these guys and Boromir
fight until he dies I mean those are
some great action same as always had
memorable fight scenes you're the first
one again it was just stretched out cuz
it made it into it surely projects like
we gotta make this gym like no you don't
really need to do a trilogy but I'm
still glad the movies around the great
yeah especially seeing this one where
everything a lot of the problems I had
with the first one or fix yeah so um
let's let's get into some more spoiler
stuff let's before we do that let's just
give our grades and our overall thoughts
I'm gonna I'm gonna give it an a minus I
think it was a very well put together
movie with a lot of good action in and
better pacing right right and I feel
like this definitely is something you
should see I saw it in 3d I did not see
in high frame rate because I hate high
frame rate soap opera [ __ ] yes it makes
everything look fake you can see like
how cheesy the props are the green
screen like the lines for the green
screen yeah I I can do a whole video
about how much I hate high frame rates
yeah I saw it in 3d and it looked great
um not high frame rate or framer no not
high frame rate is just regular old 24
frames a second um but look like most
new 3d movies just kind of gave it depth
like this few bees and insects wine or
the kind of popped in your face but it
doesn't you don't you don't have to yeah
it's not like gravity like gravity I'm
like oh you gotta see that in 3d avatar
an avatar I think Life of Pi felt like
you should see in 3d this is not one of
them know this is a movie that's like
okay you could see into danger right i
mean the projection shot in 3d like
there wasn't anything I needed to see in
three days early but for me I'm holding
back a little bit i'm gonna give it a
b-plus not that i enjoyed it more than
the first one thought this is a great
movie definitely go see it but I still
don't love it still as much as the
original trilogy which I loved but I
still this was a great improvement and I
can't wait for the next one oh one thing
to before we can display section that I
won't this isn't a spoiler but smog he
he's in it a lot yeah in the working on
other they're gonna maybe cut it off
like right when they start you know
engaging yeah well you worry like oh
maybe budget-wise I can't spend all that
money he's in it quite a bit much more
with Benedict Cumberbatch's you know
great voiceover voiceover work i also
thought a Richard Armitage as a Thorin
Oakenshield was better in this one I
felt more connected to his character in
his motivations which I think they kind
of mentioned what he was doing in the
first one but you didn't remember wrap
your head hands er I mean come on 45
minutes to get out of Hobbiton right
yeah 45 minutes you know they say a
really cool song at the end but I left
but we didn't need 45 minutes I mean
that's like the worst part if you read
anybody's read like lord of the rings of
first book Fellowship of the Ring that's
like the whole part concerning hobbits
probably the slowest part of the book
it's like okay I get it like the how
much fun they're playable it let's let's
let's get through this okay so yeah
let's get into two boilers boilers so I
want to start off first I don't talk
about since we just mentioned thorne I
want to go keep going with him I agree
with you I think its character with so
much more developed he had his little
kind of like you know you know ring
moment
doesn't have necessarily uh you know the
ring the one ring to rule them all but
he does have the Arkenstone we hear more
about the whole greed and the downfall
and how that greed brought the dragon
upon them and he you know he was getting
greedy came and there's a guy was global
gonna be richer by gonna be rich I'm
like that's not everything like you know
and that's show that how his greed
almost clouded his judgment I mean he
was ready to sacrifice Bilbo yeah yeah
he has this kind of weird relationship
with Bill boys like I need him but I
don't know if I want to need him right
they had that great Ramona at the end of
the first one where they hugged out all
that kind of went a different way in
this one yeah but then he's like okay
you go in there you get the Arkenstone
I'll wait back here because I love the
UH he's calling the ob one of the the
group the older the dwarf there or the
gray hair and he was like if you do see
anything down there he's like what's
gonna to our dragon you know this bill
was so scared yeah I think it going is
that his neck line I'll get confused or
so Nene right keeley feely worry Doreen
or ya ya botha it was my favorite that's
it and then what do you think of like
the whole relationship because some
people didn't care for it i thought it
was fine the relationship between
tauriel Evangeline Lilly's character and
I think it's Kili yeah a little nice
unless you know dwarfs getting love i
mean because they always pick on dwarf
women looking like men and all that
stuff like what Legolas looking at the
pigeons like it was this ugly / like
who's this mutant even with my son you
know so it's nice to see him you know I
don't mind it's I like that a little
better than Legolas in her well that's
more obvious choice this morning more
obviously not only that it's he's
different than what he is in much darker
yeah he's darker he's angrier more
bratty more serious he had he has more
of a joking style in in Lord of the
Rings right and also you can see how his
dad probably is influencing his dad's
kind of crazy telling all these scars
he's hiding up and all this tunnel is
crazy yeah well he chopped off that one
uh like orcs head like yeah I've been
after telling him he let him go he
doesn't want to hear it i mean he's
basically predicting the fall of you
know the return of sorrow and all this
stuff and he's just once seizes in
denial and these elves are a lot
different to they're not the elves of
Rivendell no nicer
and you know more elegant it really get
the other get away I think I'll get
drunk what's up with a drinking remember
like Legolas said that drinking
competition in two towers like he felt a
little tingling those guys were passed
out they must've drink a lot of wine
must be like some special elven elven
white little stronger so stronger okay
let's talk about smog like yeah how cool
was it to see him and see like the size
of him and they really captured I think
because they worked with Benedict
Cumberbatch so much the mannerisms the
facial expressions of it they made it
feel like not a CG character and much
more like a real not like there's real
dragon right it made it feel more real
yeah mrs. not like rain of fire I mean
this is it was so great the facial
expressions I mean you get as soon as he
like a like kind of stood up to get to
like the grin on his face like that evil
menacing sinister grin I mean
Cumberbatch's voiceover was great love
that scene when you know Bilbo's like
you know saying always like oh how great
you are any like you just like you see
is full-size we just like you know since
how do I look you know it's just he's
just great I loved everything about smog
he might have been one of the better TG
characters I've ever seen yeah definite
next day when golem came out and then we
you know this is a spoiler section the
end of the movie is basic a cliffhanger
it's after he breaks free of the golden
like takes it off yeah shakes off the
gold and then flies away and he's pissed
oh he's mad yeah he's pissed he's gonna
burn everything down right now burn the
whole mother down yeah as I wonder like
no but I think that's what a year it's
gonna come back next yeah yeah that long
away yeah but it what did you think of
that cliffhanger I think it was a good
sore it was a good point stop it was
good yeah I think so the next the next
movie we'll have smog in it and more big
battles yeah as well no thing with
gandalf being captured I mean go to
gandotra that's not you know in the that
we don't see Gandalf being captured in
The Hobbit you know so i think it's
interesting that they have him being
captured over there and I'm gonna print
our got dual I don't know how to
pronounce I had to be honest for my
negatives that was not one of my
favorite those are you okay I didn't
really care about I care about Gandalf I
think he's great i would prefer him to
stay with
the hobbits like his whole side mission
to me I just didn't really care cuz they
basically alluding to Sauron right more
for for lord of the ring I'm not like
trying to be like a purist about the
book like it has to be worked for that's
impossible no doubt patient's going to
be a stone at work for work but they're
really Lincoln that they want you to
link it i think yeah them him going away
it's like I read with him change around
maybe him go with the doors no that
would be changed some things around
understand that but yeah I didn't that
part wasn't the parts most interested in
no mostly with the dwarves you know at
the Lonely Mountain whisper smile it's
available in thorn Oakenshield even
Laketown yeah exactly when the bard the
Bowman play by Luke Evans I like that
whole dynamic between him and the
dwarves and and also you know the thorn
going in front of the people yeah look
yeah he kind of like played to their
Greek yeah yeah yeah hey I'm gonna get
all this money and be rich yeah we're
gonna help you guys out you know right
but in bard the Bowman was not happy
about that right and now we you know we
leave with our group split we have the
group on the Lonely Mountain and some
other guys you know saying behind so
yeah I mean we're gonna gonna be a lot
of stuff going on in the next movie then
there was a sequence where where were
tauriel decides to stay when healy
because he dying from the poison right
instead of helping legless which goes
offer he's not gonna be too happy about
no he's jealous he's jealous but you
know he's the king's son you know he
can't he's a he's a prince you know he
can't can't be doing with lower class
well speaking of that whole scene in
with the elves well actually wasn't just
elves there's with the dwarves too but
the whole barrel scene was awesome yeah
that was really cool scene I love L you
know Bilbo repeats that later like bill
writer you know he said I'm a barrel
right and that's what smile keeps
referring to him as his barrel-rider
that was it great I mean but she with
them Philip not so I'm gonna say
football's not civil uh bumba hey big
guy the big guy with the red beard I
love how he was just rolling around yeah
that was a great i was one of those a
great action see yes I was green eyes I
think that was something we didn't
really get in The Hobbit right just
seeing Legolas again having label us
back was
it just felt like a lord of the rings
movie with him in there I mean Orlando
Bloom essen you know he's been acting
and busy but just seen him back and Lord
of the Rings just my guess we need to be
man this is your sweet spot to get like
us so yeah this this iteration is wrap
up then this movie makes me more excited
for the third and final chapter then the
first one did for the day I agree
completely because I was the first one I
was like okay this is gonna be a serious
is going to come out it's not going to
be as good as with the Rings this new
one you think hey this is gonna this
could match you know its predecessor
which i think it is being shown in the
box office returns you know we're
filming this after the weekend of the
open well not as well as the first
example did well see the first one is
coming off of the lord of the rings
right privilege so people were super
excited to see it and so you can see
that because that it was a lesser a box
office opening right then people weren't
excited yeah huz they felt the first one
was lacking yeah you know just like I
did not that I didn't like it but that
it was lacking it was slower paced it
didn't quite have as much in there right
right so yeah we'll see you the next one
alright alright guys so you can post
your comments below on the website thing
here calm a or on our youtube channel to
hero pro make sure to subscribe to that
you all so much a Douglas on Twitter's
on Dennis and I are Michael and myself
tell us what you thought of the
desolation of smaug you can find us at
think hero i'm at griffin de that's a
facebook page that's facebook.com slash
think hero fans make sure you'd like
that page and you share and tweet in
like hour for the word
you